let's start with the Roger Scruton
affair because it's something that's
quite recently something you've written
about you were heavily involved in in
fact for anyone who didn't follow it
just tell us what happened
oh yeah the long and short of it is that
the very distinguished British
philosopher Roger Scruton now in his
mid-70s author of 40 books on a range of
subjects aesthetics philosophy
architecture music gave an interview to
a magazine in the UK called the New
Statesman and the deputy editor of the
New Statesman one George Eaton
misrepresented what had been said in the
interview a lot about what had been said
in the interview and caused wider
Scruton to be fired within five hours
from the position he held a non-stop
ndrine on an unpaid position advising a
British government crane go and this may
seem all like whereas where's a lot of
people people not familiar with Scruton
or government quangos may think well so
what so what is that I hold this very
old-fashioned view which is you
shouldn't be allowed to just lie about
people and get away with it and this was
one of the most blatant flagrant
examples of somebody doing that in
journalism it can happen in other fields
trades as well but one of the most
flavorant examples I've seen in my life
in journalism is somebody doing that and
I knew from the moment I read the
alleged quotes that they were untrue
because I've been fortunate enough to
know Roger Scruton for almost 20 years
now and I know that he doesn't think of
the Chinese a people made up of weird
robot automate ins or something I knew
that it was wrong that this this hack
had said this I looked into it sure
enough but I just guten hadn't said that
he'd said that the Chinese Communist
Party is trying to make the Chinese
people into automaton so that's just a
lie and we are all I think sadly for all
sorts of political and other reasons
becoming used to a low standard of truth
in public as in private life but
sometimes that comes right up to your
door and you just got to stop it so I
worked quite hard
recent weeks to expose this scandal and
to try to reverse it and although Roger
Scruton remains sacked from that
government role it's now known and
recognized widely that the new statesman
is deputy editor Georgie too lied
misrepresented the contents of the
interview and that this was dishonest
journalism at its worst and so um so yes
I am we turned it around a bit now one
of the things in this affair that struck
me particularly was that I think the
journalists in question had tweeted or
put something on his Instagram when he
has a picture of himself
swinging champagne for having achieved
to firing up nearly by lying about them
yeah this is particularly ugly thing to
do after after getting somebody fired
from their job he had he had George
Eaton had posted this photograph on
Instagram subsequently I removed it but
of him swinging champagnes saying the
feeling you get when you get racists and
homophobes Scruton fired from his
government position by the way the the
homophobe claim was particularly
interesting because the tape of the
interview which I subsequently acquired
showed that George Eaton himself said
something which by his own lights would
be homophobic the question he put to
Roger Scruton was you've been criticized
in the past for saying that
homosexuality is not normal but that's
just a statement of the obvious that's
what George Eaton says Roger Scruton
then says oh well no when I say not
normal normal I mean it's not the norm
in the same way that having ginger hair
isn't the norm so this journalist says
something that is homophobic and then it
tributes the homophobia to the person
who didn't say something homophobic
who's the target of his smear campaign
so it's a really interesting lesson I
think this happens sometimes in
journalism there are times when you can
just see how the whole wretched hit job
is done and that's what I wanted to do
that's why I wrote
cover piece in The Spectator a few weeks
ago now called the anatomy of a hit job
because you know I'm fortunate enough in
this position because I knew the person
who the accusations were being made
about but I mean I've been overwhelmed
by messages since but as you can imagine
by more people than usual saying look
what's happened to me and I've this has
been said about me and so on and so in a
way I think it's resonated with a
slightly wider number of people and
wouldn't normally be the case because I
think we are all we've all been becoming
familiar in recent years with the fact
that the media is not honest with very
basic thing I'm not saying all the media
I'm not saying all journalists have some
fine journalists but as as the model of
funding in journalism dies or at least
stumbles very severely it's sort of
hollowed out and I say this as a
journalist myself it's being hollowed
out and in the space of reporting and
having to really stick very carefully
facts there's been this melding
something's been happening whereby an
activist like this guy George Eaton can
go in to try to take out an interview
subject the aim of the interview is
therefore not an interview it's to do
something else and I think that a lot of
people have noticed in recent years a
tendency in television and in print
journalism to move from doing the thing
that you hold yourself out as doing and
to do something else and once you work
out what that something else is it's
very apart from the other scales for
heisman because after that people don't
trust the media again
you
[Music]